hey what's up on this video I wanted to
give a real practical video explaining
how to get your first buy to that
property investment the thing is we're
getting people watching my videos we get
people coming to my 2-day property
investors crash course they're finding
fantastic property deals now like great
how do I buy it what do I actually do
what are the ABC steps so let me go
through that on this video I hope you
she's super helpful don't forget to
smash that like button if you enjoyed
this video or these videos also
subscribe as well I'd really appreciate
that so what's gonna happen is you're
gonna first behind the deal you're gonna
find the property probably on Rightmove
assuming it's through an agent you're
gonna go in view it
you're gonna work out the numbers you're
gonna work out the return on investment
you're gonna check that it's a good
investment property
buy low rent high with a property
manager nearby I've done other videos
explaining this if you want the property
if you're interested in securing the
deal ring up the agent of putting your
offer now before I haven't put in an
offer I always try and get an idea of
what the landlord or the seller will
actually want so if it's on for a
hundred thousand pounds I'm just gonna
ring up and go I'll give you a hundred
thousand pounds I'm gonna ring up and
say I'm interested I like the house I
don't want to put in a real cheeky offer
but I am an investor so I'm looking to
get you know a bit of a deal what might
they accept and sometimes they'll just
say you need to put in your offer we
cannot give you a figure start
embarrassing you know I've done this one
other videos and put in your offer now
as soon as the offer is accepted as soon
as I've said yes they'll accept that and
it's very easy to get to that point the
estate is good five things from you so
you might want to start getting these
ready now before you even go out and
view properties please if this is what
you're gonna need
first thing is they're gonna need your
photo ID so it's going to be a passport
or a driver's license to know that
you're a real person secondly that you
need your proof of address which will be
a council tax bill maybe a utility bill
or a bank statement that shows your
address in the last three months that's
easy peasy next they're gonna need to
see your proof of deposit so if the
property is one hundred thousand pounds
your deposit is typically gonna be about
twenty five thousand pounds so they're
going to screenshot of your bank it's
going to show your name it's going to
show the amount of money that's enough
to cover the deposit on this house
they're gonna need a screenshot of that
next they're going to need to know that
you can finance the rest now if it's
buy-to-let here's the cool thing
bikes let mortgages are very easy to get
and sometimes people think because they
maybe only got experience of owning
their own home and not owning a
buy-to-let
they think that in order to get a buy to
let property they're gonna need to be on
a certain amount of earnings they're
going to need to be really good
financially they're gonna need to be in
a good well-paid job yada yada yada
that's not necessarily the case because
when you're financing a buy-to-let
property ie one that you're buying to
rent out the property should be able to
finance itself because you're renting
out so you'll find is quite easy to get
a mortgage on a basic by gellick
property even if you are in a well paid
job even if you're self-employed earning
five thousand pounds a year you should
still be able to get a buy to let
mortgage if the property comes clearly
demonstrate that it will it will pay for
itself which it which is very easy to do
if you've been on my crash course do
better find houses like that all the
time
getting a decision in principle should
be as easy as ringing up a good mortgage
broker and spending 15 minutes max on
the phone he should be able to give you
a decision in principle which is all the
agent is gonna need in order to then
take the property off the market once
your offers been on so you need to dip a
decision in principle from a mortgage
broker now if you don't know a mortgage
broker and you haven't been to my
training programs and you're brand new
and you're just starting out there's
nothing wrong with using the estate
agents in-house mortgage broker they'll
usually have an in-house mortgage
advisor in fact there's an advantage to
doing that in a way because that means
that the estate agent you've got an
opportunity to go into their office have
coffee with them let them get you the
mortgage that's the advantage it's good
for building rapport now the
disadvantage is usually if you get a
mortgage through an estate agency in
house the rates might not quite be as
good because they haven't got as many
lenders to choose from they're usually
more limited than a free independent
mortgage broker could be but that's
something you can need it's very easy to
get so just get yourself a decision in
principle lastly is who's gonna be your
solicitor again they will sometimes do
this in-house no problem using their
solicitor I would just recommend
speaking to some what
to someone who's an experienced property
investor and just ask them who they
would recommend because solicitors tend
to be either really really slow or they
just don't do anything at all having a
good sisters group but you need to give
the estate agent you'll solicit the
details and you can always change
solicitors so don't be like oh my gosh
you know I need to give the solicitor
that I'm gonna definitely use and I'm
gonna be married to you forever and you
for every property note just just give
them a solicitor speak to his sister
give them assist you can always change
it those are the five things you're
gonna need once you've given those knees
to edger this staging will take the
property off the market and then the
estate agent will then lays with your
mortgage advisor who's your finance in
the deal and your solicitor and they'll
do everything and all you need to do is
just phone them up every couple weeks
and say how's it going don't chase them
and be a dick don't be like hurry up
what's going on I'm paying you tip no no
because then they'll just be annoyed
with you ring them up regularly and say
is there anything I can do to speed this
up can I do anything
here's the thing when you're investing
in property when you do your first
buy-to-let property typically or take
two to four months for the house to go
through before you view it and you get
the keys which is an awfully long time
here's my rule of thumb when the ball is
in your court
ie you need to sign something or you
need to send off a bank statement or
show your proof of ID or whatever when
the balls in your court get it out fast
but when the ball is in other people's
caught you've got to be patient you've
got to be patient because if you get
super impatient you can annoy everybody
welcome to the game of property
investing it takes time so hope that's
been helpful please do smash that like
button if that was really useful don't
forget to subscribe share the video and
put your comments below I'll try and
read every single one
peace out I'll see you next time
you
[Music]